I'm curious in like uh like American
music right like if somebody who did
kind of like the type of music that
you're known for doing kind of like
switched up and did some like trap
hip-hop uh there might be some like uh
negative feedback or people thinking
that like hey you know this is not what
you do like do you do you are you
getting any of that type of feedback
from your fans or from fans I'm sorry
fans are complicated and when I say
complicated um it takes them a little
bit of time to like accept what you're
doing
and the fans are they they go with the
flow like I said when I when I first
droppedo pacto was my trap song right
now it's like my why is she going crazy
right yeah it's going crazy right now
and people are like I don't know Jay I
miss you I missed the and I that was
only one song and people were like I
miss you
and after that song I I dropped the
whole album with romantic music but with
one song people were like I missed the
OJ where is Jay
and as soon as I did the remix and anuel
and Ryan Myers would were in the remix
people were like okay I love this J
sounds like already gold in Spain I
think or yeah yeah it is and and right
now people are like okay I love this J I
love the fact that Jason is trapped so
it's excellent it takes out the a little
bit of time to like make your fans
except that you're doing something new
but when you do something new you have
to be careful when you do it and how you
do it because
um you need to like you can't just go
out of whatever it is that you're doing
right just do something new right so
that's why I'm in this album I'm
dropping like a little bit of both like
I'm doing romantic songs but in a trap
in a r b traffic type of beat you know
right right so and and I'm doing side
songs and I'm doing like sex songs and I
don't like songs that talk about drugs
I'm doing all of it but I am trying to
like keep the jaywiller the J Will
Revive on those you gotta keep those
those day one fans exactly exactly
um I was gonna ask you uh as somebody
who's from Puerto Rico I know you're
living in the States now how do you feel
about some of the like uh people who are
moving to Puerto Rico for tax benefits
because I saw like I think the Paul
Brothers live there like Logan Paul
lives there I don't know well how does
it feel I mean there's some people that
are mad about it yeah because I know
some people are mad but then some people
are like well it helps the economy a
little it kind of sheds no idea how to
feel yeah I I I'm the one that says that
if you're If he if he doesn't like harm
people right and do whatever you want to
do do whatever you think is better for
you and yourself because at the end of
the day like you can try to work four
people you can try to do everything for
people but not every people deserve so
if you're like if you're happy if you
doing something that you think is
correct for your for your
I don't know for your money for your for
your you still have like a main
residence in Puerto Rico I don't my mom
my mom does you should have your address
as your mom's address so the U.S tax
thing you know they ain't in your
[__] pie I should yeah I wish you
live in Florida and there's no state tax
but I'd be like guys I live in Puerto
Rico my mom's address is my address yeah
no I I I I haven't done that and then
you put the Florida house in your best
friend's name yeah
yeah I could do that and then you just
you save money because [__] the IRS like
really you know what I mean I mean
you're right when does the album come
out uh
um probably we're working and we're
doing our best to drop it in October
October yeah very soon but I'm dropping
singles though that the first who do you
have on the album
right now which is the the pacto remix
with anuel Ryan Myers all of them uh I'm
trying to get luwal again which is a
trap artist too that he is in pacto the
original but he's gonna be I'm trying to
make him in a one of the sad songs that
I have okay I'm trying to get a verse of
him and he said yes he already dropped
the first part I haven't like just
structured the songs I have a newbie
which is a a new artist from Puerto Rico
and I have a couple more but I can't say
because I'm surprised okay so album's
coming in October track yes sir go
support it